[Musik]
hallo wach erlebnis
ihr seid schon bei uns dreht sich alles
um das thema einschulung denn im
september wird die familie eingeschult
kommen sie in die erste klasse und ich
habe noch gar nicht verstanden wie
schnell die zeit eigentlich vorbeigehen
und der schulranzen des steht jetzt
schon den haben wir vor kurzem geholt
heute geht es um das thema schultüte
aber vielleicht noch ganz kurz zu deinem
schule rannte
warum hacken von hübsch jetzt aber noch
ein schutzengel mit dran
und jetzt ist startklar für die schule
oder den schulranzen haben wir vor
kurzem in einem fachmarkt in machen
gekauft damit wir unterwegs und haben
uns auch wirklich beraten lassen
nur noch der zugwagen dass sich das sei
empfehlenswert findet denn als spieler
selber konto lehrerin und ich habe auch
eine erste klasse und die kinder werden
heutzutage auch wirklich früher
eingeschult als früher bei mir ich war
damals mit sieben erst an der reihe und
geht heute teilweise auch kinder die
schon mit fünf eingeschult werden
das heißt wir sind von der körperstatur
noch gar nicht so groß und gerade in dem
alter macht es wirklich sehr viel auf ob
man als fünf sechs oder sieben ist und
es gibt einfach kinder die sind von
grund auf ein bisschen zierlicher und
dünner andere die sind ein bisschen
kräftiger und größer und daher ist auch
der richtige schulranzen wirklich gold
wert vor allem für den rücken des kindes
und auch einfach so für die gesundheit
und da gibt es einfach verschiedene
modelle das heißt es gibt etwas
schlankere modelle es breitere modelle
und es gibt einfach ganz normale modelle
und ich sind ganz wichtig dass man sich
da eben gut beraten lässt damit der
schulranzen auch wirklich zu dem rücken
des kindes passt das heißt dass
schulranzen sollte hier hinten einfach
mit dem rücken des kindes abschließen
und einfach nicht viel viel breiter sein
außerdem kann man hier oben die höhe
einstellen wird aus der schule und
wirklich auf schulterhöhe abschließt
aber so wie jetzt hier und zwar gibt's
hier drinnen einen reißverschluss den
müssen die eltern dann einmal öffnen
oder einfach im fachmarkt gemeinsam mit
der verkäuferin machen
hier ist eine kleine scheibe und wie
kann man mit namen zu drehen und tod und
einfach hier dieses rückenteil nach oben
oder nach unten verstellen und ich hoffe
wirklich einmalig machen und dann wenn
das kind mit wächst und halbes jahr
später oder eingangs später kann man das
ganze wieder verstellen der verhandlung
soll er auch wirklich von klasse 1 bis
klasse zu halten
wird man wirklich erst in der
weiterführenden schule wieder einen
neuen schulranzen braucht es ist auch
ganz wichtig das kind alleine mit dem
ranzen zurecht kommt das heißt hier
einmal auf dessen bitte und dass der
schulranzen auch ohne inhalt nicht zu
schwer ist es kommen ja noch bücher mit
rein noch eine wasserflasche mit rein
und am besten auch nicht immer zu voll
packen so dann gibt's noch hier dieses
schmalen genau dann liegt das nicht auch
ein bisschen auf der hüfte und ganz
verteilt auf den schultern auf nicht
verdrehen und dann am besten hier noch
mal nachsehen und hier und dann sitzt du
gut oder sehr schön das thema
schulranzen kümmern wir uns später am
ende des videos noch einmal
jetzt geht es aber um das thema bei mir
war und die schultüte
denn heute möchten wir gemeinsam eine
schultüte basteln markanten schon fertig
kaufen diese schultüte hier haben wir
online gekauft weiterwandern
da gibt es wirklich verschiedenen shop
geht uns jetzt die caritas gemacht sogar
mäuschen heißt sie da und es wirklich
auch sehr sehr schön vor allem sehr
individuell mag anbieter einfachen
muster aufsuchen und die applikationen
aussuchen und dann einfach im eigenen
design wählen und wird dann eben mit dem
namen noch individualisiert heute möchte
ich euch aber zeigen wie auch ihr ganz
einfach eine schultüte machen können und
war mir hier einmal ein beispiel mit dem
schmetterling und wir haben hier noch
ein beispiel mit dem fußballer da stehen
jetzt noch keinen namen braucht denn die
super schultüten möchten wir gerne am
ende des videos an euch verlosen
das heißt sobald ich dann meister die
gewonnen hat kommen hier natürlich auch
noch der name drauf ich würde sagen wir
legen gleich los
für die schultüten brauchen wir
natürlich ein bisschen bastelbedarf und
damit decken wir sind kurz ein
[Musik]
bekommen also die grundform dafür nehmen
wir ganz festen tonkarton also foto
karton am besten und müssen ebenso einen
viertelkreis ausschneiden dabei ich euch
jetzt wie das ganz einfach geht
und zwar mich jetzt hier einen tonkarton
in größe einer din a 1 und dann braucht
ihr einen bleistift und eines muss und
dann legt er jetzt im bleistift hier
vorne an zerfalls an der kurzen seite
und die eine hand fixiert mit einem
finger den faden hier außen und jetzt
macht ihr mit einer großen bewegung
einen kreis und den viertelkreis für ein
schiff mit einer schere ganz fertig aus
die tonkarton festzulegen so einfach auf
die weite und die nehme ich dann eben
noch für die deko für eine schultüte
braucht ihr zwei solche viertel greife
einfach nur mit die schule denn bis ein
stabiler erstmal mit der später auch auf
freien fuß einfach und mühelos mehr
einfüllen von daher einfach zwei
übereinander nehmen ich wäre froh dafür
auch und weiß für ihnen nehmen und jetzt
nehmt ihr die seite mit den
bleistiftzeichnungen als mit dem
bleistift linge hier einfach für ihnen
und armenische schultüte gleichen
bisschen besser formen kann damit dass
papieren weiter wird sich einfach das
ganze hier über die kante
[Applaus]
und dann sieht man schon das papier sich
schon anfängt zufrieden weil wir es
einmal zur probe
lasst uns schön einer spitze bilden
und gerade weil eben der karton bisschen
besser ist geht's am anfang etwas
schwieriger aber das passiert alles ganz
so aus das heißt da habe ich jetzt schon
schultüten form und kann jetzt aufmachen
und festkleben
ich empfehle dabei immer doch seitiges
klebeband zu nehmen weil es einfach
sofort fixiert ihr könnt also auch vom
beispiel in gestik nehmen oder auch
einen flüssigen kleber aber da müsste
halten bis den hals und es ist alles weg
ich hab sie mir ein bisschen helfen und
da müsste jetzt auch wirklich nur die
eine seite
also müssen wir hier mit klebeband drauf
machen
bei der inneren tüte ist es gar nicht
schlimm dass ich jetzt hier nicht
komplett exakt hier am rand entlang den
klebestreifen habe aber bei der äußeren
tüte ist es ganz wichtig der ansonsten
fixiert es nicht und steht später so
unschön ab genaues kann es hier ab 10
[Musik]
mit ganz vorsichtig kleben das kommt
echt nur einmal machen sonst was man
sich die tüte kaputt unten am besten die
spitze fixieren und mit der anderen hand
rollen und dann haben jetzt hier schon
mal die fertig erschüttert
macht gar nichts da kommt das später
noch im raum warum gibt nämlich noch
zweite stück wie gesagt habe ich hier
den halb den viertelkreis und
zurechtgeschnitten und jetzt auch wie
eben erwähnt diesen klebestreifen ganz
am rand da kann es jetzt auch abziehen
da kommt noch mal ein klebestreifen auf
die andere seite kannst du mal
wegschneiden gesetzlich getötet hier
unten an
das heißt zuerst die spitze dann hier
oben und das drumherum kleben und diese
unschöne spitze hier unten die
verwechseln wir jetzt gleich sowieso das
kann ich jetzt erstmal zur seite legen
die schule ist so im rohzustand schon
einmal fertig für die spitze nehme ich
immer gerne dekorpapier das heißt und
gemusterte hier nämlich jetzt ein
gestreiftes auf der rückseite habe ich
gepusht und sah die spitze ist nicht wie
es nach oben geht sondern nur ein kurzes
stück könnte weiß auch nur in kleinen
zirkel greif machen
den mache ich jetzt auf die rückseite
damit ich die streifen wieder nicht
szene
das heißt der csr kleiner und ein
kleiner kreis gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
man könnte die spitze auch mal zur probe
anlegen und wenn ihr euch gefällt wieder
mit klebeband verdächtige anstecken die
spitze und wartet am samstag den
überrest hier oben dem schneider ist
einfach ganz grob wächst auch nicht zu
genau sein denn wenn wir das gleiche
software deckt damit sie die schultüte
später befüllt und auch vermieten können
benötigen wir noch ein bisschen basteln
film ich habe jetzt hier ein kind
gewesen und werde sofern sie jetzt 30 cm
breit ausschneiden
[Musik]
und was auch hier am einfachsten geht
nämlich auch hier wieder doppelseitiges
klebeband und lebt hier oben an den rand
das heißt ich schreibe etwa 15 cm dick
so lange ich hier unten bei diesem
beschluss an das heißt dass beide nähte
einfach auch hinten bleiben lege ich
jetzt hier den filz an
ganz vorsichtig und klebten einmal
drumherum
[Musik]
und den überflüssigen in dem ich jetzt
weg
dass aber etwa zwei zentimeter stehen so
dass da einfach wird überschuss liegt
die beiden teile übereinander legen und
nicht offen steht und den überresten
klebe ich jetzt auch noch mal fest
und im prinzip steht so schon mal die
grundstruktur das heißt die schultüte
wäre jetzt so fertig und kann fertig
dekoriert werden
falls ihr euch diesen part bisschen
ersparen möchte gibt's auch schon
vorbereitete schultypen
das heißt man kann auch diese rohlinge
zum beispiel kaufen reduzieren blau
rowling dann auch schon den film oben
dran
das heißt man braucht man eben nur noch
eine band zum festbinden und kam danach
noch so ein laune den ganzen rowling
dekorieren
das machen wir jetzt auch gleich das
heißt du bekommst es noch eine kleine
schultüte sie bereiten mir jetzt noch
zusammen vor und damit dekoriert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die dekoration mache ich jetzt auch
moskau dafür nehme ich mir jetzt drei
verschiedenen farben und damit sie auch
meine schablonen aus papier selbst
vorgezeichnet und aufgeschnitten und
kann jetzt so diese schablone benutzen
um das muss gummi zu recht beschneiden
[Musik]
das dunkle lila nehme ich jetzt für den
grund schmidt und deshalb nehme ich
jetzt damit der schmetterlinge ein
bisschen lebendiger wirkt
[Musik]
im körper streikt dann auf hellem rosa
zurecht und klebe dann alle teile mit
alleskleber zusammen und lassen
schmetterlinge erstmal durch trocknen
[Musik]
mehr
hier habe ich jetzt ein paar verschieden
große kreise aus tonkarton
aufgeschnitten
betis übereinander kleben und dann werde
ich schultüte damit dekorieren
[Musik]
noch
jetzt darf der schmetterling noch ein
bisschen funkeln und dafür nehme ich
jetzt einen glitzer kleber den benutzt
man ganz einfach wie einen stift strikt
hinauf und dann trocknet der über nacht
ganz gut durch
[Musik]
und dafür hab ich mir jetzt einen
fußball motiv aufgesucht
[Musik]
für den fußballer habe ich mal eine
schablone gezeichnet und werde jetzt die
elemente aus tonkarton so schneiden und
die dann auf die schippe drauf geben
[Musik]
mit mio
denn
[Musik]
die schuldtitel nicht so weit fertig wir
haben jetzt hier ein bisschen zu acht
gelassen
für den namen der nahrung vom kind muss
natürlich auch mit drauf deswegen auch
genug platz
aber den können wir erst aufmachen wenn
die schultüten verlost sind und ich
natürlich weiß ich dass kindheit und
jetzt brauchen wir natürlich noch ein
bisschen kordel oder schnur zum
verbinden netz zu finden und da nehme
ich jetzt einfach hier diese beweist die
zwei farben für den schmetterling und
grün und blau wird diese schuld
[Musik]
und bei den beiden kordeln hier
verknotete ende damit die kordel einfach
nicht aufgehen
[Musik]
das
aber jetzt sind wir fertig falls
halbfertig sobald ich weiß wer von euch
diese schultüten gewonnen hat werde ich
natürlich noch die namen drauf schreiben
und die ganzen ganze sendung
das heißt die schultüten werden und sie
klingt gefüllt da kommt noch ein
bisschen was rein und hier haben wir
noch zwei schulranzen zu verlosen
und zwar machen wir das ganze ist so
wahr mir machen jetzt eine gewinnfrage
und dann dürft ihr gerne in die
kommentare schreiben ob ihr gerne die
blaue schultüte gewinnen möchte den
blauen zu bremsen
den roten schulranzen oder die
pinkfarbene schultüte für das ganze wie
sollen wir das machen
sag mal eine frage
[Musik]
das vollständig am meisten
da freue ich mich auch schon und jetzt
freue ich mich auf eure kommentare wie
gesagt schreibt einfach in die
kommentare rein machen davon gewinnen
möchte
und wir melden uns doch einfach
schriftlich bei euch und falls ihr diese
schulbücher jetzt auch gerne nach
basteln wollen dann wünschen wir euch
jetzt noch einmal ganz viel spaß dabei
[Musik]